welcome to the presentation on averages
average is probably a concept that
you've already used before maybe not in
a mathematical way but you know people
will talk in terms of the average voter
wants the politician to do this or the
average student in the class wants to
get out early so you're probably already
familiar with the concept of an average
and you probably already intuitively
knew that an average is just a number
that represents the the different the
different values that a group could have
but it can represent that as one number
as opposed to giving all of the
different values and let's give a couple
of examples of how to compute an average
and you might already know how to do
this so let's say I had the numbers 1 3
5 and 20 and I asked you what is the
average of these four numbers well what
we do is we literally just add up the
numbers and then divide by the number of
numbers we have so we say 1 plus 3 is 4
so let me write that 1 plus 3 plus 5
plus 20 equals let's see 1 plus 3 is 4 4
plus 5 is 9 9 plus 20 is 29 right and we
had 4 numbers 1 2 3 4 so 4 goes into 29
it was 7 7 28 and then we have 10 I
didn't have to do that decimal there go
to 825 so 4 goes into 29 7.2 five times
so the average of these four numbers is
equal to seven point two five and that
might make sense to you because seven
point two five is is is someplace in
between these numbers and we can kind of
view this seven point two five as one
way to represent these four numbers
without having to list these four
numbers there are other representations
you'll learn later on like the mode
you'll also see that the mean which
we'll talk about later is actually the
same thing
the average but the average is just one
number that you can use to represent a
set of numbers so let's do some problems
which I think are going to be close to
your heart let's say on the first four
tests of an exam I got a let's see I got
an 80 80 and 81 and 87 and an 88
what's my average in the class so far
well all I have to do is add up these
four numbers so I say 80 plus 81 plus 87
plus 88 well 0 plus 1 is 1 1 plus 7 is 7
set 1 plus 7 is 8 8 plus 8 is 16
I just ran 8 miles so I'm a bit tired
and then you have 4 eighths so that's 32
plus 1 is 33 and now we divide this
number by 4 4 goes into 336 it goes into
33 8 times 8 times 4 is 32 33 minus 32
is 116 4 so the average is equal to 84
so depending on what school you go to
that's either a B or C so so far my
average after the first four exams is an
84 now let's make this a little bit more
difficult we know that the average after
4 exams hit for exams
is equal to 84 now if I were to ask you
what do I have to get on the next test
to average an 88 to average an 88 in the
class right
so let's say that X is what I get on the
next test so now what we can say is is
that the first four exams I could either
list out the first four exams that I
took or I already know what the average
is so I know the sum of the first four
exams is going to be four times 84 and
now I want to add the what I get on the
fifth exam X and I'm going to divide
that by all five exams so notice this
number is what is the average of my
first five exams we just figured out the
average of the first four exams but now
we sum up the first four exams here we
add what I get on the fifth exam and
then we divide it by five because now
we're averaging five exams and I said
that I need to get an 88 in the class
and now we solve for X so let's make
some space here so 5 times 88 is let's
see five times a D is 400 so it's four
forty four forty equals four times
eighty four we just saw that is 320 plus
16 is 336 336 plus X is equal to 440 it
turns out if you subtract three 36 from
both sides you get x is equal to 104 so
unless you have a exam that has some
bonus problems on it it's probably
impossible for you to get an 88 average
in the class after just the next exam
you'd have to get 104 on that next exam
let's just look at what we just did we
said after four exams we had an 84 what
do I have to get on that next exam to
average an 88 in the class after five
exams and that's what we solved for when
we got X now let's ask another question
I said after four exams after four exams
I had an 84 average
if I said that there are six exams in
the class and the highest score I can
get on an exam is 100 what is the
highest average I can finish in the
class if I were to really study hard and
get 100 on the next two exams well once
again what we'll want to do is sit
assume we get 100 on the next two exams
and then take the average so we'll have
to solve up all six exams so we're going
to have the average of 6 so we're in the
denominator we're going to have 6 the
first four exams the sum is we already
learned is is a for exams times the 84
average and this dot is just x + there's
going to be two more exams right because
there's six exams in the class and I'm
get 100 in each so that's two hundred
and what's this average well four times
84 we already said is 336
plus 200 over six so that's five thirty
six over six six goes into five thirty
six I don't know if I give myself enough
space but 6 goes into 53 eight times 48
56 goes into it 9 times 9 times 6 is 54
6 minus 26 goes into so we'll see it's
actually 89.3 33333 it goes on forever
so 89.3 repeating so no matter how hard
i try in this class the best I can do
because I only have two exams left even
if I were to get 100 on the next two
exams I can finish the class with an 89
0.333 average hopefully I think some of
this might have been a little bit of
review for you you already kind of had a
sense of what an average is and
hopefully these last two problems not
only taught you how to do some algebra
problems involving average but they'll
also help you figure out how well you
have to do on your exams to get an A in
your math class I think you're now ready
for the average module I have fun